Kim Kardashian is safely back on us soil  after being held at gunpoint tied up and  robbed at her apartment in Paris on  Sunday Kim and her husband Kanye West  were seen walking into their new york  city apartment just after 11 a.m. on  monday kim shiz her face away from the  cameras while Kanye walks behind her  clearly worried about his wife also  arriving at the apartment mom Kris  Jenner appearing upset before Kim landed  Kanye looked somber while walking out of  the apartment last night he abruptly  stopped his live performance in Queens  when news broke his wife was robbed I'm  sorry family emergency after stop show a  rep for Kim previously told ET she was  confronted by two armed masked men who  posed as police officers quote she is  badly shaken but physically unharmed